par après
mais là
parce que moi
l'article est bien servi par xavi
aïe
ben amor
un court extrait du court métrage
brottes de woods qui a obtenu une
nomination aux oscars dans la catégorie
meilleur court métrage de fiction le
film aborde un sujet tellement sensible
tellement d'actualité au moment où on
vit ces grandes tensions au moyen orient
le sujet du retour des djihadistes dans
leur famille après avoir combattu auprès
du groupe armé islamique en vous avez eu
le regard du père et de son fils les
traitent entre les frères et bois de
rose raconte ce dilemme moral d'un père
de famille quand son fils aîné il
revient à la maison
après ce séjour en syrie il est déchiré
entre ses valeurs et la loyauté envers
sa famille c'est quand même son sens son
fils alors je reçois la réalisatrice du
film meriam joober j'espère qu'on enlève
votre nom félicitations merial
bonjour est l'une des productrices maria
gracia turgeon qui connaît en route
parce que l'année dernière elle avait
produit fauves ce court métrage qui
était aussi en nomination félicitations
à vous aussi je mets rien pigé d'écrire
un peu votre parcours vous êtes
tunisienne d'origine
vous avez grandi aux états unis après
notamment septembre 2001 vous êtes très
sensibles à ces questions là vous avez
étudié à concordia le cinéma et vous
avez tourné ce film quand et nous le
décor du film comment est née cette idée
oui a donc les films on a su téléfilm
dans une petit village dont les normes
de tunisie et en 2016
j'ai fait un voyage là bas juste pour
connecter deux démons payet pays
d'origine et dans cette place j'ai
trouvé trois frères kim a capté beaucoup
parce que son visage sans très spécial
avec les cheveux roux un âge où seraient
exactement je suis désolant des eaux
exactement c'était les mêmes choses que
je pense qu'angers
j'ai les vues et dans le petit vers le
but avant le père mohamed mais qu'il est
un acteur connu exactement donc dans
cette moment j'ai demandé à ce que je
peux pris une photo il dit n'ont pas de
photo mais pour année un an et demi
après j'ai toujours pensé à eux et j'ai
écrit le scénario
parce que j'ai appris que beaucoup de
cette région spécifiquement allait déjà
allés en syrie pour la région du nord de
l'italie pas loin de votre village natal
s'impose comme une forme de pèlerinage
pour vous de retourner away exactement
c'était pour koné plus mon pays déroger
donc après une heure et demie j'ai écrit
le scénario et j'y allais chercher pour
les quarts sans cela vous entrez les
convaincre en fait la richesse de ce
reportage à bas par le sujet vous voyez
bien mais c'est de mettre en scène trois
vrais frères qui vivent cette fraternité
avec deux parents acteurs mais confronté
à ce choix ce prix est extrêmement
difficile
des djihadistes de leur retour je séduis
vous renseigner au point de vous
l'impression de films à la base mais là
mais moi ça fait longtemps qu'on
collabore enfin on se connaît depuis
vous comptez aujourd'hui depuis déjà six
ans et on est quand même des
collaboratrices créative très proche
d'être sûr que aussi que myriam a une
idée de film je pense que je j'ai
toujours envie d'embarquer dans ses
projets j'adore l'univers qu'elle crée
la sensibilité qu'elle amène sur des
sujets donc je me verrais pas faire un
film sensuel et j'ai l'impression que
vice versa également bien surtout quand
on a parlé du film je pense avant même
de lire le scénario était déjà
emballé par la proposition par ses
sujets qui étaient extrêmement riche et
sensible
puis en lisant le scénario ça nous
convaincre très rapidement la marque est
actuellement faire un film avec un enjeu
aussi fondamental à être fidèle à sa
famille il est là c'est assez valeur
comment vous êtes-vous jamais vous de
juger ne porte pas de jugement sur cette
personne oui à ça c'était très important
pour moi de créer une caractère comme te
dis dans les débuts de l'infini ils
voient aller la vie en noir au blanc
mais quand on les fait hurler film fini
il change il voit que la vie c'est plus
complexe
un look total ouais ça c'est les
tragédies dans les films ils voient ça
trop tard un message je trouve très
important parce que maintenant dans
l'est dans le monde je trouve que les
communications à arrive ça qu'ils aient
percé en et un gros division dans les
communications donc mohamed pas moi
représente les besoins pour moi les
complique les complexités et ghzali ce
déchirement exactement le personnage la
mer est un film qui a fait le tour du
monde et participé à plus de 150
festivals soixantaine de prix dont les
plus importants sont dans le film
toronto qui vous ont versé que si valve
vous ouvre la porte des aspects qu'est
ce que ça représente pour lui de redire
pour eux vous leur avez parlé
aujourd'hui à mohamed et
à sa faculté à 100 très contente parce
que aussi les films c'est un couple
coproduction entre québec canada et la
tunisie et pour l'utiliser sur les
points première fois que il utilisait
les nominés donc c'est une grand chose à
là bas tout le monde est fier surtout
les équipes là bas et je vois que le
fils va beaucoup d'événements visionnant
utilisé quel a été l'accueil du film là
bas est ce que ça va fils était bien le
dilemme
oui a vraiment un donc marie aussi
devient atomisé peut-être un peu partout
lorsque j'ai trouvé près frappant en
fait c'est que en tunisie ils l'ont pris
avec plus d'humour le film dans le sens
où il ya des femmes qui sont très très
forte qu'ici on avait des salles où les
spectateurs c'est silence complet la
scène du souper où il va avoir une
grosse confrontation entre le père et le
fils
alors qu'en tunisie à ce moment là les
gens se mettaient à rire je pense y
aussi une certaine décomplexion la botte
du problème est de justement cette
espèce de confrontation entre autres
applis facilement smith était plus parce
que donc dans cette scène il y a un gîte
jeu de mots le maire de meaux de moi oui
acquis mohamed fait que c'était un peu
difficile mais c'était une frappe quand
elles frappent son fils avec des mots
les tunisiennes sont les
mais les c'est quoi la whey le pouvoir
le pouvoir de ces mondes des femmes
c'est pour ça aiderait parce que c'est
très fort mais on a trouvé une façon de
dire entre les chaînes autres que les
silences aussi ça va être important pour
vous pour votre carrière que ce prix si
vous remportez le statut elle c'est
important au niveau de je pense que déjà
juste de se rendre à la nomination
d'avoir le système peu de l'académie
dire c'est un film qui a été nominé aux
oscars saviez déjà amené tellement je
pense qu ce qu'on m'a dit l'année
dernière aussi que je pense que la
réalité c'est que d'être nominé fait
presque mieux entre guinée parce que des
fois de gagner justement cela même
tellement une pression sur ce qui vient
après que souvent ce qu'ils gagnent un
peu de difficulté avec tout ça et vous
voulez en faire un long métrage avec les
mêmes personnages
mon frère si vous qu'elle épouse du bien
soit la même histoire grâce à ses 6 25
petites minutes sont très innovant oui
assez le même famille mais dans une
autre façon et une prospective différent
aussi
mais on peut voir plus de communautés
six communes merci beaucoup en france on
sera à vos côtés en pensée avec vous
plaît que vous visitez retournerez avec
les longs métrages
merci beaucoup